l'étude
moi quand je pars en vacances en france
et que dit ouais j'aime nord et que je
commence à dire valenciennes denain à
tous sa mission demande si je peux avec
ma soeur comme que
[Musique]
la police municipale mme armand se
déplace à moto cross donc vraiment
la classerie ya des algériens des
marocains des français on est tous
ensemble
salut ses amours et je vous emmène à
denain donnant c'est une des villes les
plus pauvres de france et là bas la moto
et le foot américain ça fédère pas mal
de jeunes et grâce à ça j'ai pu
rencontrer clément il est coach de foot
américain et à miner la 16 ans et les
fous de backelite
alabak la mct une équipe là plusieurs
tas des motos et des quads vécu du haut
elle je suis va donner dans toutes les
villes et c'est ça la vraie bataille pas
vrai la salon moto je connais plein de
monde maintenant
j'ai commencé la moto j'avais 9 ans et
quand je crains bien faire du du voile
et où je vais 11 12 ans ça fait
longtemps que
[Musique]
à voir avec ça je te dis tu fais tous
les revêtements de là dessus qu'ils
décompressent directement tu peux rouler
pendant une heure comme ce qu'on voulait
10 heures sans t'arrêter tellement c'est
bien j'ai de l'amour pour la bécane
comme si c'était ma meuf
[Musique]
j'ai fait plein de trucs pour me payer
des motos vraiment je faisais des pommes
de terre dans l'échangé rebordé ouais je
te jure c'est vrai je faisais tout des
affaires avec des vélos des trottinettes
des pommes de terre je vendais des
betteraves tu veux savoir aussi un rôle
à la tête de ma mère c'est vrai gros
avec ça j'ai monté mon argent je leur
dis de la potiche voir des to 2 to 2 to
de tout ça les vans et savane bien plus
bas voilà
[Musique]
enrique c'est soit tu cours tu t'en vas
tu te dépêches maintenant les denaisiens
faut aller les chercher c'est le truc
qui s'il faut aller les chercher et je
n'ai pas souvenir que pour bosser fall
est assis par terre les gars fait
coiffer club med ici il ya des gars ma
part par trenet ils ont ils font rien de
leur journée parce qu'ils sont
intéressés par rien
les supports suivants suivant à la si tu
veux du brut football américain peuvent
être servis
le sport c'est une manière de
s'émanciper et puis de sortir un peu de
son quotidien par importe le milieu
social moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est quand
un gamin il n'a pas de passion il n'a
pas de hobby il a pas d'activité
il regarde c'est un peu le terrain comme
on disait aux gens comme marcelo
le tout
de
même 6 et s'échoue la gamme aura beau là
tout le monde dirait bien
tout le monde ya que des geishas donna
comme je t'ai dit à des spécimens t'as
jamais vu ça dans les autres villes
samedi et c'est un match qu'on doit
gagner
impérativement c'est quoi la règle quand
on est absent ouais prévenir juste dire
absents j'ai pas besoin de vos excuses
et j'ai surtout pas besoin de vous
excuse fausse que dis je suis pas là je
bosse on voit tes story instat à namur
je zapperai pour qui des guignols non
peut-être mais répondent même pas tu as
cru qu'on avait 70 ans qu'on n'était pas
sur instagram a été le foutent de notre
gueule t'es pas là tu dis je suis pas là
avant non pas des couilles qui passe
mieux georges travail alors qu'avec ta
gonzesse à namur arrêtez de nous vendre
du flandre
tout ce que je dis au coin c'est parti
pour les diago
mon frère c'était un passionné de moto
aussi était vraiment fort en moto j'irai
vraiment lui-même suis pas au prix il
m'a après j'étais tout petit c'est à
dire lui me prenait devant et j'ai
accéléré balles et plusieurs accidents
et à jour passe et l externe trop
apprêtée il rentrait du terrain était
fin de journée l'entrée du terrain et
hors du terrain a fait un accident est
décédé
ah ouais je pensais m'en offrir tous les
jours plus tard quand je roule en moto
je pense à mon frère je dors pas tous
les jours les jours je me promène
[Musique]
vrai nom même est pareils voulait que
j'arrête il voulait pas que je continue
la moto quand ils nous voyaient sur une
moto n'avait plus de ressortir
[Musique]
amine il a une histoire familiale un peu
compliqué aujourd'hui il vit avec sa
tante parce qu'il parle plus du tout
avec sa mère bah merde je la vois tout
le temps mais bas comme je vous ai dit
je parle pas avec après ça reste ma mère
c'est sûr bon je vais pas dire le
contraire
on perd chez lui ben issa al tu peux
beaucoup c'est à dire moi je veux pas
les déranger mais après il ya déjà des
petits et tout c'est pour ça après mon
père il fait sa vie de son côté moi je
fais la vidéo belle ma vie de mon côté
mais mon père on est toujours en contact
tous les jours on s'envoie des messages
tout le temps il prend des nouvelles de
moi je prends des nouvelles de lui après
comme je vous ai dit ici franchement
c'est vraiment tous mes frères chacun
c'est à dire si un jour si demain la
rive à percer que j'arrive à gagner
quelque chose devait tous partagent avec
eux
au football vous avez votre taf
individuellement qui doit participer à
la réussite collective
réfléchissez à ça les gars dans la
solidarité dans le collectif donnant ces
villes ouvrières enfin c'était une ville
ouvrière où le taux de chômage avoisine
les 35 % et c'est bien au dessus des
moyennes nationales moi mon père me dit
tout le temps à l'époque ici la plus
grosse ville c'est valenciennes dit moi
quand j'étais jeune personne par l'eba
l'ancien la grosse ville s'était donné
je me suis fait mourir originaux
travailler 24 heures défaut des journées
de 24 heures faut le dire et maintenant
je me retrouve à la rue sans rien il ya
40 ans les industries métallurgistes
donc en l'occurrence usinor a fermé ce
qui a mis énormément de gens au chômage
un effet dévastateur
ça c'est fermé il ya 40 ans et je pense
que la ville dense on s'est toujours pas
remis complètement à chaque fois je
tombe sur une photo de mes grands pères
je les vois ils sont face à face en
train de parler et il ya la bouteille de
ricard devant eux étudient bon là c'est
sûr ils sont en train de parler d'usinor
en train de se faire un jeune c'est
évident c'est j'ai tellement vécu ça
toute mon enfance
voilà
les cafés ont fermé les parents fermé il
ya un cinéma qui vient de rouvrir la
demain depuis depuis six mois maintenant
avant que le cinéma arrive là ya six
mois il ya peu de cinéma demain pendant
je sais pas combien d'années c'est alors
que c'est une ville de 20 mille
habitants les activités
à dia la moto ce cd lambda way est un
vrai bas je pourrais dire que la moto
franchement
après les matchs viffort ya des pokers
trois des stars
[Musique]
je trouve ici à deux n'a pas de parent
ou dans la ville
aujourd'hui 30 police la police depuis
la police depuis hier et pour que de
venir chez vos sources
wale à cause de ça du reportage
je remercie
il atterrit juste derrière le stade on
sait très bien que les gamins avec leurs
motos ils vont encore une fois c'est
peut-être parce que on les oriente pas
vers d'autres choses donc quand ils sont
livrés à eux mêmes ils font ce qu'ils
savent faire
peut-être que si on les avait intéressés
à d'autres choses ou même carrément des
clubs de moto parce que ça existe aussi
des gens qui font ça de façon très
structuré et que
si vous voulez peut-être
peut-être avoir des futurs talents
venait à demain retrouvez
il a
tort
j'ai grandi dans sa savez moi aussi j'ai
roulé en est parti appuie aussi à
l'emprunt et d'orties
[Musique]
la
dépense que la sorte qu'ils posteront
pays mais sinon on partout dans la ville
des ponts n'est vraiment beaucoup de
bien la boîte livre
[Musique]
il arrive
bon les gars je vais pas y aller par
quatre chemins les pirates ne viendront
pas ils sont forfaits pour ce match
j'aime pas gagner comme ça j'aime pas
comment ça se passe et si le match et
eux ils sont encore en lice eh bien on
ira chez eux parce que s'ils ont la
flemme de venir jusqu'à demain de
normandie et ben non on montrera qu'on
n'a pas la flemme et qu'on est prêt à
aller chez eux
pour leur mettre le cul par terre nous
l'adaptation qu'on a choisi aujourd'hui
c'est de s'entraîner malgré tout et on
essaye de de mettre sa frustration dans
dans l'entraînement qui vient
et vega la lega expliquez moi un truc
pourquoi me fait vous avez su être
agressif et ultra dominant la pendant un
quart d'heure et là vous êtes nous comme
des chèvres nous on participe de facto
au fait que les jeunes soient moins
isolé puisque nous avec le club sur les
cinq dernières années on envoyait chaque
année au moins un jeune au pôle france
de football américain et il y en a deux
aussi qu'ils sont partis ou qui vont
partir au continuer l aventure football
américain au canada c'est des jeunes qui
n'auraient peut-être jamais voyagé s'il
n'y avait pas eu à un moment donné le
football américain sur trois
n'ont jamais jeu mais je vais à mon rêve
franchement c'est d'aller rouler avec
les mecs aux états unis
[Musique]
reportage j'espère que cette vidéo vous
a plu et si vous voulez voir d'autres
contenus d'autres reportages n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à la chaîne youtube
de brut est aussi laissez moi des
commentaires je les lirai et je vous dis
à bientôt
[Musique]